this is the first year that the Academy
has made available to membership on DVD
all denominated live-action shorts so
pay attention because he came from where
do you where do you come from
they made short films right they made
short films so our future a listers are
right here in this envelope here are the
nominees for Best live action short film
Assad Bryan Buckley and me no George or
booze Kashi boys Sam French and Ariel
NASA Sean Christianson Daffy of a shadow
Doronin shadow Tom Donovan or
and Ellen devala Henry Yan England
and the Oscar goes to curfew Sean
Christian
is the first Academy Award nomination
for
Kristensen
Wow a big thank you to the Academy for
supporting short films this has been
wonderful and I only have t-minus two
seconds to do this so I'm just gonna go
for it
my producer in crime Damon Russell I
Love You Man we would not be here
without you brother my co-star 12 year
old co-star Fatima pathetic your
performance was so incredible nobody
even remembers I'm in the film because
of you you are incredible
Marik Hassan and Renee Pierre thank you
so much the incredible cinematography
from daniel cats and putting together
that wonderful crew thank you so much
all of our friends family crew in New
York and in France want media caliber
Media Verve talent my beautiful mother
my devilishly handsome father and the
center of my universe my dearest Nina
thank you I love you all